president joe biden's in britain it's
his first foreign trip since
taking the white house and unlike when
trump came here there are no
blimps for biden instead uh joe and
boris went for a lovely walk here they
are
standing in front of a big g7 with their
wives
and then um took a lovely stroll down
the beach
lovely romantic if anything and they
also um
went to this museum in cornwall and joe
there
with an absolute bell strictly speaking
it's not like
joe biden chose boris and britain as his
first port of call
it's just a coincidence before he got
here there's uh there was
talk like this from biden at every point
along the way
we're going to make it clear that the
united states is
back and democracies of the world are
standing together
to tackle the toughest challenges so
basically
if you're in the middle east duck thing
is
every time a uk prime minister and a u.s
president meet
we have to go through the biggest
charade in global politics
the cringe fest that is the debate over
the special
relationship so what is the special
relationship
we could go into uh stuff like shared
cultural ties and shared language
shared history the fact that
intelligence agencies
share everything together et cetera et
cetera but i'm going to let
boris explain it here i'm not going to
descend from that one
i'm not going to disagree with the
question or indeed on anything else
basically it means whenever america goes
to war britain will go to war with it
and they'll bond the same patch of
desert together
not because britain is particularly
useful in terms of its military
but it is politically useful in a kind
of arse-covering
coalition of the willing kind of way in
return
britain gets um well it gets to go to
war as well
apparently they've agreed this time to
sign a new atlantic charter
the old one was signed by churchill and
roosevelt after the second world war
see there's always a war with all that
being said the unspoken truth is nothing
is complete bs
not even unspoken at this point everyone
knows it in fact
the debate always surrounds how
embarrassing it is that everyone has to
spend their time
saying special relationship special
relationship
a special relationship kudos to boris
johnson this time around though because
apparently he recently told a journalist
that he doesn't want to use the term
anymore
he says he thinks it makes britain
appear needy and weak
which is the last thing he wants to do
here's a clip of him backtracking
what are you two gonna call it now i
look i don't mind i don't i don't mind
the the the phrase special
relationship but over the years biden
has made no secret that his real special
relationship
is with bit orcs island mr biden quick
word for the bbc
bbc i'm irish ahead of arriving in
britain this time his loyalties were
clearly on display again
so the reports are that he threatened
boris that if any of his post-brexit
trade shenanigans
threatened peace in northern ireland
that would be very bad now the times of
london reports that washington
accused london of inflaming tensions
with ireland
and europe and issued a dimash that's a
formal way of saying they sent someone
over
to issue an in-person diplomatic
spanking
the kind of spanking which is usually
kept for enemies
and not allies with whom you have a
special relationship
so perhaps the best thing you can say
about the special relationship
as we say in britain is it is a bit
special